there's a line in the books or I said
the reader lives a thousand lives before
he dies the man who does not read lives
only one and for me that's been true the
life of the imagination has made my own
life much richer it allows us to walk a
forest of the night and see wonders and
terrors it's painted in broad strokes
hey guys Pete here that was a clip from
Apple where george RR martin talks about
his new enhanced book series that's
coming out on iBooks i'll talk a little
bit a little bit more about that later
and show you a little bit more of the
footage soaked up we bless where the
weekly spoiler video was and with the
holidays there really wasn't any news
this week but this is going to be a
spoilers video so if you don't want to
see what's going on in season 7 filming
for Game of Thrones or any cast news or
anything like that then you'll want to
stop watching now with that out of the
way let's jump right into it so the only
thing that popped up before the holiday
was that Joseph malwa I think that's how
you pronounce his name the guy who plays
Benjen stark showed up in Belfast just
before they finished filming we had a
picture of him sitting with tormund and
Jorah at a bar with some lucky fans and
beyond that we really don't know what's
going on he was there for the wolf hill
quarry scene I'm sure which you know we
know is going to be a battle most likely
with the night King so it's pretty
likely that he's going to lend a hand
when things go against our friend Jon
Snow that'll be actually pretty cool I
mean it'll be nice to see another stark
reunion the bad part here is that it
will probably spell the end for Uncle
Benjen for sure if he has to come and
save his nephew John snow from the night
king so I guess the best we can hope for
is that he'll be able to hold them off a
little bit longer than summer did
whenever the direwolf sacrificed itself
if I remember correctly the leak said
something about this happening and even
without that information it makes the
most sense of you know that's what
Benjamin would be there for I don't
think he'll meet up with them before the
battle and you know he would be there to
help out in the situation which can
really only end in a crisis I mean going
against the night King it doesn't matter
who you have it's a bad situation from
there we got a couple new photos from
the week before when they were filming
in Croatia nothing too exciting we get
to see some gold cloaks and some things
like that but we've actually already
seen the more exciting stuff from that
the last video so there was also all the
usual social media stuff in this photo
of emilia clarke on her instagram pretty
much sums up what we should expect for
the next week or so you can see that she
says this is what a day off feels like
and not surprisingly the rest of the
cast I'm sure was on break kit harington
who plays John Snow did have a birthday
over this time but we didn't see
anything exciting related to that past
that there was a little bit of news that
wasn't spoilers you know george RR
martin has announced officially that the
graphic novel for the mystery nights
going to come out this isn't a big
surprise because we've already seen the
graphic novels for the first to dunk and
egg books but at least we know for sure
when this is going to come out it'll be
hidden in the summer on the fourth of
july of 2017 the other thing we got is
the announcement for the digital books
version that's coming out on iBooks for
all the all of the original novels the
ad is actually really cool because it
shows george RR martin talking about
different aspects of the stories and
sort of reading some passages and the
digital book actually looks pretty cool
too i mean he sells it he says it's you
know it's like a new era in publishing
or whatever and you know but it looks
like you can actually you know look
things up and have access to a lot of
the extra features that wouldn't be
involved with just reading a paper book
i mean i'm a way more of a fan of actual
paper books and i don't really like to
get money to Apple much but I am fine
with giving money to george RR martin
obviously and you know this kind of puts
all the best of you know you know read
the book and use the internet but
actually a very closed specific internet
for the book at the same time so it's
probably pretty cool but beyond that we
don't really have anything else this
week so what i'm going to do is starting
tomorrow I'm going to start doing recaps
of what we know already I figured out
how I'm going to split them up so it'll
make the most sense and the first one
will be about all the characters we
hadn't seen for a while who
back up and then we'll go through all
the main characters and storylines in
four or five days so I hope you guys
will check back for that sorry this was
a shorter video but it is another chance
to win in the book giveaway so make sure
you subscribe now and leave a comment
and from there once I hit 28 thousand
subscribers i will pick one commenter
from these videos and i will send them a
copy of the 20th anniversary of a game
of thrones by george RR martin there'll
be a link in the description for that
and if you have any questions about the
spoilers that we've had so far make sure
you leave them in the comments and I'll
try to get to them in that recap series
please go and check out my are the gods
real series I put out I put it around
Christmas and didn't get very many views
so it's a kind of a disappointment
because I want to make part 3 but if no
one's going to watch it then I guess I
probably won't alright thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon first
scene I wrote in the book was tough
finding it a dire wolf pups in the
summer snow and I knew it was the summer
snows that phrase was there right from
the beginning the mother wolf dead gave
birth even as she was dying with a
broken off antler of a stag in her
throat
I do try with my words to convey what
I'm seeing as the scene lives in my head
to make it live in your head as well the
Iron Throne in my mind's eye dominates
the throne room completely it's made of
thousands of sorts and they were melted
down by dragons fire and hammered into
shake it's asymmetric it's ugly it's a
monstrous beast once there were two
moons in the sky but one wandered too
close to the Sun and cracked from the
heat a thousand thousand dragons poured
forth drank the fire of the Sun as the
nearest Targaryen rose to her feet the
black mist hail smoke venting from its
mouth and nostrils I am the sword in the
darkness I am The Watcher on the walls I
am the fire that burns against the cold
the light that brings the dawn geography
is destiny in a sense I want the
genealogies I want the histories I think
it adds immeasurably to the reality and
the richness of the world